nothing could ruin this
postseasonic stinks at the Washington
football time hurry stop the leaks
oh Mr Snyder was the ground toxic waste
I am suing you for raising your voice
[Music]
look your dump is too toxic you're right
we need to make serious changes for real
introducing the commander Hawk track
balance
the big star cheerleaders are all male
because women won't come near us so it's
still a dump no one will fall whoa
okay but did you actually clean the
inside of the dump based on the parts of
the dump I was shown kind of can't
criticize us because we honored Sean
Taylor with a commemorative trash
connect
please buy merch Ryder 100 to park at
the trash Palace of course sorry Dan
it's King Snyder you peasant we're also
the first garbage dump to honor the
troops I'm President Joe Biden and this
is what will unite us wait I think the
dump is falling apart Oh look The
English one it's clear there's only one
thing to do build them a dump in
Northern Virginia
foreign
obviously I was hoping for the red wolf
trash Den but I could get used to this
maybe now everyone will shut up about
the name and we can focus on all the
promising trash in the draft Yeah I just
hate Dan Snyder oh hello I'd like to
give your organization all my time and
money how quickly